Let's consider a
very simple example
of a runner in which our
position function x of t
is given as a quadratic
function in time.
It will be a constant
b times t squared.
Here, b is a constant.
Now it's always
important in SI units
to consider what the
units of this constant is.
Because a position function
is measured in meters
and time is measured in
seconds, b is a constant
and it has units of
meters per second squared.
And there's an
example of a runner--
and let's make a plot of
that position function.
So we're going to plot x
of t as a function of time.
b here-- let's make b
a positive constant.
And so our function looks
something like that.
Now, the velocity-- component of
the velocity-- remember v of t
is given by dx dt
of this function.
And the derivative of
a polynomial t squared
is very simple.
That's just simply 2b times t.
Again, let's look at our units.
Because b has the units of
meters per second squared,
and when multiplying
that by second,
we have the units of velocity in
SI units as meters per second.
Now let's plot that function.
Notice this is a
linear function.
And so if I plotted
underneath here, the velocity
as a function of time, it
starts off with a zero slope.
Remember we're looking-- our
velocity at any given time
corresponds to the slope of a
tangent line to the position
function.
And you can see that
slope is increasing.
Now you wouldn't know
it from this graph,
but if you did plot t squared,
it's increasing linearly.
And so our velocity
function-- the initial slope
is 0 at t equal 0, and it's
increasing linearly in time.
So we'll just draw that
as some linear function.
And the slope here
of this function
will be now the acceleration.
So a of t is the derivative of
the component of the velocity
function as a function of time.
And this derivative
is quite easy.
It's just simply 2 b.
Now notice those have
the units of meters
per second squared, which
are units for acceleration.
When we, again,
look at the slope,
notice that at
every single point,
the slope of the velocity as a
function of time is a constant.
The slope here is
just equal to 2b.
And so now if we plotted
our acceleration function,
we have this point 2 b,
and every single point
has the same value
of acceleration.
So here the acceleration
is an example
of constant acceleration.
And this is our simplest case.
Notice we started with
the position function.
We differentiate to get the
component of the velocity
and to get the component
of the acceleration.
So this is a very simple
model for a runner
whose increasing speed
linearly, accelerating
at a constant rate.